how the economic machine works in 30
minutes
the economy works like a simple machine
but many people don't understand it or
they don't agree on how it works
and this has led to a lot of needless
economic suffering
i feel a deep sense of responsibility to
share my simple but
practical economic template
though it's unconventional it has helped
me to anticipate and to sidestep the
global financial crisis
and it has worked well for me for over
30 years
let's begin though the economy might
seem complex
it works in a simple mechanical way it's
made up of a few simple parts
and a lot of simple transactions that
are repeated over and over again
a zillion times these transactions are
above all else driven by human nature
and they create three main forces that
drive the economy
number one productivity growth number
two
the short-term debt cycle and number
three
the long-term debt cycle we'll look at
these three forces and how laying them
on top of each other
creates a good template for tracking
economic movements and figuring out
what's happening now
let's start with the simplest part of
the economy
transactions an economy is simply the
sum of the transactions that make it up
and a transaction is a very simple thing
you make transactions all the time
every time you buy something you create
a transaction
each transaction consists of a buyer
exchanging money
or credit with a seller for goods
services
or financial assets credit spends just
like money
so adding together the money spent and
the amount of credit spent
you could know the total spending the
total amount of spending drives the
economy
if you divide the amount spent by the
quantity sold
you get the price and that's it that's a
transaction
it's the building block of the economic
machine
all cycles and all forces in an economy
are driven by
transactions so if we can understand
transactions we can understand the whole
economy
a market consists of all the buyers and
all the sellers making transactions for
the same thing
for example there is a wheat market a
car market
a stock market and markets for millions
of things
an economy consists of all of the
transactions in all of its markets
if you add up the total spending and the
total quantity sold
in all of the markets you have
everything you need to know to
understand the economy
it's just that simple people businesses
banks and governments all engage in
transactions the way i just described
exchanging money and credit for goods
services and financial assets
the biggest buyer and seller is the
government which consists of
two important parts a central government
that collects taxes and spends money
and a central bank which is different
from other buyers and sellers because it
controls the amount of money and credit
in the economy
it does this by influencing interest
rates
and printing new money for these reasons
as we'll see
the central bank is an important player
in the flow of
credit i want you to pay attention to
credit credit is the most important part
of the economy
and probably the least understood it's
the most important part because it's the
biggest
and most volatile part just like
buyers and sellers go to the market to
make transactions
so do lenders and borrowers lenders
usually want to make their money into
more money
and borrowers usually want to buy
something they can't afford
like a house or a car or they want to
invest in something like starting a
business
credit can help both lenders and
borrowers get what they want
borrowers promise to repay the amount
they borrow
called principal plus an additional
amount called interest
when interest rates are high there is
less borrowing because it's expensive
when interest rates are low borrowing
increases because it's cheaper
when borrowers promise to repay and
lenders believe them
credit is created any two people can
agree to create credit
out of thin air that seems simple enough
but credit is tricky because it has
different names
as soon as credit is created it
immediately turns into debt
debt is both an asset to the lender and
a liability to the borrower
in the future when the borrower repays
the loan
plus interest the asset and the
liability disappear
and the transaction is settled so why is
credit so important
because when a borrower receives credit
he is able to increase his spending
and remember spending drives the economy
this is because one person's spending is
another person's income
think about it every dollar you spend
someone else earns
and every dollar you earn someone else
has spent
so when you spend more someone else
earns more
when someone's income rises it makes
lenders more willing to lend him money
because now he's more worthy of credit a
creditworthy borrower has two
things the ability to repay and
collateral
having a lot of income in relation to
his debt gives him the ability to repay
in the event that he can't repay he has
valuable assets to use as collateral
that can be sold
this makes lenders feel comfortable
lending him money
so increased income allows increased
borrowing
which allows increased spending and
since one person's spending is another
person's income
this leads to more increased borrowing
and so on
this self-reinforcing pattern leads to
economic growth
and is why we have cycles
in a transaction you have to give
something
in order to get something and how much
you get depends on how much you produce
over time we learn and that accumulated
knowledge raises our living standards
we call this productivity growth
those who are inventive and hard-working
raise their productivity and their
living standards faster
than those who are complacent and lazy
but that isn't necessarily true over the
short run
productivity matters most in the long
run but credit
matters most in the short run this is
because productivity growth doesn't
fluctuate much
so it's not a big driver of economic
swings debt is
because it allows us to consume more
than we produce when we acquire it
and it forces us to consume less than we
produce when we have to pay it back
debt swings occur in two big cycles
one takes about five to ten years and
the other takes about
75 to 100 years while most people
feel the swings they typically don't see
them as cycles because they see them too
up close
day by day week by week in this chapter
we're going to step back and look at
these three big forces
and how they interact to make up our
experiences
as mentioned swings around the line are
not due to how much
innovation or hard work there is they're
primarily due to how much
credit there is let's for a second
imagine an economy without
credit in this economy the only way i
can increase my spending
is to increase my income which requires
me to be more productive
and do more work increased productivity
is the only way for growth since my
spending is another person's income
the economy grows every time i or anyone
else is more productive
if we follow the transactions and play
this out we see a progression
like the productivity growth line but
because we
borrow we have cycles this isn't due to
any laws or regulations
it's due to human nature and the way
that credit works
think of borrowing as simply a way of
pulling spending
forward in order to buy something you
can't afford you need to spend more than
you make
to do this you essentially need to
borrow from your future self
in doing so you create a time in the
future that you need to spend
less than you make in order to pay it
back
it very quickly resembles a cycle
basically
anytime you borrow you create a cycle
this is as true for an individual as it
is for the economy
this is why understanding credit is so
important because it
sets into motion a mechanical
predictable
series of events that will happen in the
future
this makes credit different for money
money is what you settle transactions
with
when you buy a beer from a bartender
with cash
the transaction is settled immediately
but when you buy a beer with credit
it's like starting a bar tab you're
saying you promise to pay in the future
together you and the bartender create an
asset
and a liability you just created credit
out of thin air it's not until you pay
the bar
tab later that the asset and the
liability disappear
the debt goes away and the transaction
is settled
[Music]
the reality is that most of what people
call money
is actually credit the total amount of
credit in the united states is about 50
trillion dollars
and the total amount of money is only
about three trillion dollars
remember in an economy without credit
the only way to increase your spending
is to produce more but in an economy
with credit
you can also increase your spending by
borrowing
as a result an economy with credit has
more spending
and allows incomes to rise faster than
productivity over the short run
but not over the long run now don't get
me wrong
credit isn't necessarily something bad
that just causes cycles
it's bad when it finances over
consumption that can't be paid back
however it's good when it efficiently
allocates resources and produces income
so you can pay back the debt for example
if you borrow money to buy a big tv
it doesn't generate income for you to
pay back the debt
but if you borrow money to say buy a
tractor
and that tractor lets you harvest more
crops and earn more money
then you can pay back your debt and
improve your living standards
in an economy with credit we can follow
the transactions and see how credit
creates growth
let me give you an example suppose you
earn a hundred thousand dollars a year
and have no
debt you are credit worthy enough to
borrow ten thousand dollars
say on a credit card so you can spend a
hundred and ten thousand dollars even
though you only earn a hundred thousand
dollars
since your spending is another person's
income someone is earning a hundred and
ten thousand dollars
the person earning a hundred and ten
thousand dollars with no debt
can borrow eleven thousand dollars so he
can spend
a hundred and twenty one thousand
dollars even though he has only earned
a hundred and ten thousand dollars his
spending is another person's income
and by following the transactions we can
begin to see how this process
works in a self-reinforcing pattern but
remember
borrowing creates cycles and if the
cycle goes up
it eventually needs to come down this
leads us into
the short-term debt cycle
as economic activity increases we see an
expansion
the first phase of the short-term debt
cycle spending continues to increase and
prices start to rise
this happens because the increase in
spending is fueled by credit
which can be created instantly out of
thin air
when the amount of spending and incomes
grow faster than the production of goods
prices rise when prices rise
we call this inflation
the central bank doesn't want too much
inflation because it causes problems
seeing prices rise it raises interest
rates
with higher interest rates fewer people
can afford to borrow money
and the cost of existing debts rises
think about this as the monthly payments
on your credit card going up
because people borrow less and have
higher debt repayments
they have less money left over to spend
so spending slows
and since one person's spending is
another person's income
incomes drop and so on and so forth
when people spend less prices go down
we call this deflation economic activity
decreases
and we have a recession if the recession
becomes too severe and inflation is no
longer a problem
the central bank will lower interest
rates to cause
everything to pick up again with low
interest rates
debt repayments are reduced and
borrowing and spending pick
up and we see another expansion
as you can see the economy works like a
machine
in the short term debt cycle spending is
constrained only by the willingness of
lenders and borrowers to provide and
receive credit
when credit is easily available there's
an economic expansion
when credit isn't easily available
there's a recession
and note that this cycle is controlled
primarily by the central bank
the short-term debt cycle typically
lasts five to eight years
and happens over and over again for
decades
but notice that the bottom and top of
each cycle finish
with more growth than the previous cycle
and with more
debt why because
people push it they have an inclination
to borrow and spend more
instead of paying back debt it's human
nature because of this over long periods
of time
debts rise faster than incomes creating
the long-term debt cycle
despite people becoming more indebted
lenders even more freely extend
credit why
because everyone thinks things are going
great
people are just focused on what's been
happening lately
and what's been happening lately incomes
have been rising
asset values are going up the stock
market roars
it's a boom it pays to buy goods
services and financial assets with
borrowed money
when people do a lot of that we call it
a bubble
so even though debts have been growing
incomes have been growing nearly as fast
to offset them
let's call the ratio of debt to income
the debt burden
so long as incomes continue to rise the
debt burden
stays manageable at the same time asset
values soar
people borrow huge amounts of money to
buy assets as
investments causing their prices to rise
even higher
people feel wealthy so even with the
accumulation of
lots of debt rising incomes and asset
values help
borrowers remain creditworthy for a long
time
but this obviously cannot continue
forever
and it doesn't over decades debt burden
slowly increased
creating larger and larger debt
repayments
at some point debt repayments start
growing faster than incomes
forcing people to cut back on their
spending and since one person's spending
is another person's income incomes begin
to go down
which makes people less credit worthy
causing borrowing to go
down debt repayments continue to rise
which makes spending drop even further
and the cycle reverses itself
this is the long-term debt peak debt
burdens have
simply become too big for the united
states europe and much of the rest of
the world this happened in 2008
it happened for the same reason it
happened in japan in 1989
and in the united states back in 1929.
now the economy begins deleveraging
in a deleveraging people cut spending
incomes fall credit disappears asset
prices drop
banks get squeezed the stock market
crashes
social tensions rise and the whole thing
starts to feed on itself the other way
as incomes fall and debt repayments rise
borrowers get squeezed no longer credit
worthy
credit dries up and borrowers can no
longer borrow enough money to make their
debt repayments
scrambling to fill this hole borrowers
are forced to sell assets
the rush to sell assets floods the
market at the same time as spending
falls
this is when the stock market collapses
the real estate market tanks and banks
get into trouble
as asset prices drop the value of the
collateral borrowers can put up drops
this makes borrowers even less credit
worthy
people feel poor credit rapidly
disappears
less spending less income less wealth
less credit less borrowing and so on
it's a vicious cycle this appears
similar to a recession but the
difference here
is that interest rates can't be lowered
to save the day
in a recession lowering interest rates
works to stimulate
borrowing however in a deleveraging
lowering interest rates doesn't work
because
interest rates are already low and soon
hit zero percent
so the stimulation ends interest rates
in the united states hit
zero percent during the deleveraging of
the 1930s
and again in 2008
the difference between a recession and a
deleveraging
is that in a deleveraging borrower's
debt burdens have simply gotten too big
and can't be relieved by lowering
interest rates
lenders realize that debts have become
too large to ever be fully paid back
borrowers have lost their ability to
repay and their collateral has lost
value
they feel crippled by the debt they
don't even want more
lenders stop lending borrowers stop
borrowing
think of the economy as being not credit
worthy
just like an individual so what do you
do about it deleveraging
the problem is debt burdens are too high
and they must come down
there are four ways this can happen one
people businesses and governments cut
their spending
two debts are reduced through defaults
and restructurings
three wealth is redistributed from the
haves to the have-nots
and finally four the central bank prints
new money
these four ways have happened in every
de-leveraging in modern history
[Music]
usually spending is cut first as we just
saw people businesses and even
governments tighten their belts and cut
their spending so that they can pay down
their debt
this is often referred to as austerity
when borrowers stop taking on new debts
and start paying down old debts
you might expect the death burden to
decrease
but the opposite happens because
spending is cut
and one man's spending is another man's
income it causes
incomes to fall they fall faster than
debts are repaid and the debt burden
actually gets worse
as we've seen this cut in spending is
deflationary and painful
businesses are forced to cut costs which
means less
jobs and higher unemployment this leads
to the next step
debts must be reduced many borrowers
find themselves unable to repay their
loans
and a borrower's debts are a lender's
assets when a borrower doesn't repay the
bank
people get nervous that the bank won't
be able to repay them
so they rush to withdraw their money
from the bank
banks get squeezed and people businesses
and banks default on their debts
this severe economic contraction
is a depression a big part of a
depression
is people discovering much of what they
thought was their wealth
isn't really there let's go back to the
bar
when you bought a beer and put it on a
bar tab
you promised to repay the bartender
your promise became an asset of the
bartender
but if you break your promise if you
don't pay him back
and essentially default on your bar tab
then the
asset he has isn't really worth anything
it has basically disappeared many
lenders don't want their assets to
disappear and agree to debt
restructuring
debt restructuring means lenders get
paid back less
or get paid back over a longer time
frame or at a lower interest rate than
was first agreed
somehow a contract is broken in a way
that reduces debt
lenders would rather have a little of
something than all of nothing
even though debt disappears debt
restructuring causes
income and asset values to disappear
faster
so the debt burden continues to get
worse
like cutting spending debt reduction is
also
painful and deflationary all of this
impacts the central government because
lower incomes and less employment
means the government collects fewer
taxes
at the same time it needs to increase
its spending because unemployment has
risen
many of the unemployed have inadequate
savings and need financial support from
the government
additionally governments create stimulus
plans
and increase their spending to make up
for the decrease in the economy
government's budget deficits explode in
a deleveraging because they spend more
than they earn in taxes
this is what's happening when you hear
about the budget deficit on the news
to fund their deficits governments need
to either
raise taxes or borrow money
but with incomes falling and so many
unemployed
who is the money going to come from the
rich
since governments need more money and
since wealth is heavily concentrated in
the hands of a small percentage of the
people
governments naturally raise taxes on the
wealthy
which facilitates a redistribution of
wealth in the economy
from the haves to the have-nots the
have-nots who are suffering begin to
resent the wealth he has
the wealthy halves being squeezed by the
weak economy
falling asset prices and higher taxes
begin to resent the have-nots
if the depression continues social
disorder can break out
not only do tensions rise within
countries they can rise between
countries
especially debtor and creditor countries
this situation can lead to political
change
that can sometimes be extreme in the
1930s this led to hitler coming to power
war in europe and depression in the
united states
pressure to do something to end the
depression increases
remember most of what people thought was
money was actually credit
so when credit disappears people don't
have enough money
people are desperate for money and you
remember who can print money
the central bank can
[Music]
having already lowered its interest
rates to nearly zero it's forced to
print money
unlike cutting spending debt reduction
and wealth redistribution
printing money is inflationary and
stimulative
inevitably the central bank prints new
money out of thin air
and uses it to buy financial assets and
government bonds
it happened in the united states during
the great depression
and again in 2008 when the united states
central bank
the federal reserve printed over two
trillion dollars
other central banks around the world
that could printed a lot of money too
by buying financial assets with this
money it helps drive up asset prices
which makes people more creditworthy
however this only helps those who own
financial assets
you see the central bank can print money
but it can only buy financial assets
the central government on the other hand
can buy goods and services
and put money in the hands of the people
but it can't print money
so in order to stimulate the economy the
two must cooperate
by buying government bonds the central
bank essentially lends money to the
government
allowing it to run a deficit and
increase spending
on goods and services through its
stimulus programs
and unemployment benefits this increases
people's income
as well as the government's debt however
it will lower the economy's total debt
burden
this is a very risky time policy makers
need to balance the four ways that debt
burdens come down
the deflationary ways need to balance
with the inflationary ways in order to
maintain stability
if balanced correctly there can be a
beautiful deleveraging
[Music]
you see a deleveraging can be ugly or it
can be beautiful
how can a deleveraging be beautiful
even though a deleveraging is a
difficult situation
handling a difficult situation in the
best possible way is beautiful
a lot more beautiful than the
debt-fueled unbalanced
excesses of the leveraging phase in a
beautiful deleveraging
debts decline relative to income real
economic growth is positive
and inflation isn't a problem it is
achieved by having the right balance
the right balance requires a certain mix
of cutting spending
reducing debt transferring wealth and
printing money
so that economic and social stability
can be maintained
people ask if printing money will raise
inflation
it won't if it offsets falling credit
remember
spending is what matters a dollar of
spending paid for with money has the
same effect on price as a dollar of
spending paid for with credit
by printing money the central bank can
make up for the disappearance of credit
with an increase in the amount of money
in order to turn things around the
central bank needs to not only pump up
income growth but get the rate of income
growth
higher than the rate of interest on the
accumulated debt
so what do i mean by that basically
income needs to grow faster than debt
grows
for example let's assume that a country
going through a deleveraging has a debt
to income ratio of a hundred percent
that means that the amount of debt it
has is the same
as the amount of income the entire
country makes in a year
now think about the interest rate on
that debt
let's say it's two percent if debt is
growing at two percent because of that
interest rate
and income is only growing at around one
percent
you will never reduce the debt burden
you need to print enough money to get
the rate of income growth above the rate
of interest
however printing money could easily be
abused because it's so easy to do and
people prefer it to the alternatives
the key is to avoid printing too much
money and causing
unacceptably high inflation the way
germany did during its deleveraging in
the 1920s
if policymakers achieve the right
balance a deleveraging isn't so dramatic
growth is slow but debt burdens go down
that's
a beautiful deleveraging when incomes
begin to rise
borrowers begin to appear more
creditworthy and when borrowers appear
more creditworthy
lenders begin to lend money again debt
burdens finally begin to fall
able to borrow money people can spend
more eventually the economy begins to
grow again
leading to the reflation phase of the
long-term debt cycle
though the deleveraging process can be
horrible if handled badly
if handled well it will eventually fix
the problem
it takes roughly a decade or more for
debt burdens to fall in economic
activity to get back to normal
hence the term lost decade
in closing of course the economy is a
little bit more complicated than this
template suggests
however laying the short-term debt cycle
on top of the long-term debt cycle
and then laying both of them on top of
the productivity growth line
gives a reasonably good template for
seeing where we've been
where we are now and where we're
probably headed
so in summary there are three rules of
thumb that i'd like you to take away
from this
first don't have debt rise faster than
income
because your debt burdens will
eventually crush you
second don't have income rise faster
than productivity
because you'll eventually become
uncompetitive
and third do all that you can to raise
your productivity
because in the long run that's what
matters most
this is simple advice for you and it's
simple advice for policy makers
you might be surprised but most people
including most policy makers don't pay
enough attention to this
this template has worked for me and i
hope it will work for you
thank you
[Music]
you